faire un bon café c'est pas sorcier ça
prend de bons grains bien torréfié mais
surtout la bonne mouture la mouture et
crucial si c'est trophées pour
l'application il bloque si c'est trop
grossière il laisse le penser à travers
son réagir et c'est pour savoir quelle
mouture utiliser qu'une charte calibrée
de 100 à 1200 microns a été créé plus le
chiffre est petit plus le grain sera fin
plus le chiffre est élevé plus la
mouture sera grossière
il y a deux mondes entre le sammicron et
le 1200
mais pour vous montrer qu'est-ce que ça
donne ceci pour les briques qui est sans
micro-ondes une poudre comme la farine
après ça vous avez le
600 microns pour le militant après ça
vous avez
1200 microns donc saint 61 12
chaque type de café à son gratte de
mouture ainsi le bonhomme aura une
mouture comparable aux gros sel alors
que celle du café filtre s'approche
plutôt de la texture du sel l'expresso
quant à lui aura une mouture qui
ressemble à de la farine quand le café
est moulu plus fin c'est que ça ouvre
les ports donc ça permet une plus grande
surface d'extraction donc comme la durée
est souvent plus courte on doit extraire
plus de café pour pouvoir avoir les
saveurs qu'on recherche tandis que si on
parle par exemple d'un bonhomme on a
besoin d'une mouture qui est beaucoup
plus grossière ça ça va nous permettre
en fait comme le grain est plus gros
d'infuser plus longtemps sans avoir une
surextraction des gants au Alexandre
Seguin offre un service personnalisé aux
amateurs de café souvent ce qu'on va
demander en fait c'est quel type de
machine vous avez à la maison et
qu'est-ce que vous buvez puis on va
adapter en fait la mouture selon la
machine c'est le paramètre le plus
important finalement à respecter donc on
a beau avoir le meilleur café du monde
si il est pas moulu pour le type
d'extraction qu'on a à faire on n'aura
pas un bon résultat qu'est-ce qui arrive
si je prends le 600 pour faire un
Nespresso
si votre machine est performante l'eau
il va défoncer à travers le café vous
aurez pas de la crème et ça va être
juste une
de l'autre teintée de café et si je
prends 5
au brûler votre pont
mais c'est un micro pour faire un café
filtre par exemple vous allez avoir un
débordement de votre panier si on mou
trop faim donc on va avoir une sur
extraction donc la surextraction du café
va souvent amener un goût qui est très
très amer qui est très très astringent
au contraire si on nous trouve grossier
mais à ce moment-là l'extraction va être
trop rapide donc ça va être sous extrait
et puis ça ça amène souvent des notes
qui sont plus sur plus aigre beaucoup
d'acidité nous avons préparé deux
expresso de façon
identique mais avec des moutures
différentes à droite une mouture
expresso à gauche une mouture à café
filtre alors qu'est-ce que ça donne
notre expérience visuellement c'est par
là donc visuellement vous voyez que vous
avez environ 600 microns
c'est 8 secondes d'extraction le 300
microns
avec 25 secondes d'extinction vous allez
voir que c'est pratiquement
vous avez la crème qui tient encore
malgré que ça fait à peu près une plus
que 1 minute et demi qui est resté là
mais c'est fou les différences
et même au nez ces personnes
ça c'est pas mal la complexité est
complètement
fade parce que c'est pas l'extinction
ici vous allez avoir les goûts de
caramel le barbe et tout
[Musique]
pouvez-vous fier dessus mais faut aussi
être conscient que ces moulins là sont
pas vraiment conçus pour donner le
meilleur des
je dirais de spécifications ou de
calibration nécessaire la précision de
mouture et la grandeur de particules et
la distribution des particules il
pourrait se différer d'un moulin d'une
épicerie à l'idéal ça serait de pouvoir
moudre à la minute donc à la maison
juste avant la préparation du café mais
quand c'est impossible mieux vaut avoir
la bonne mouture un petit peu moins
fraîche que d'avoir une mouture fraîche
mais qui n'est pas appropriée à la bonne
méthode d'extraction
[Musique]